Basically, we all must have heard about vaccines,
but do we know
why we prefer more common vaccines?
Basically, the vaccines are either
given in our mango or in our hip
area, but mostly.
Vaccines are generally preferred
because the fat layer here is
very thin due to which your
antigens can easily enter your blood vessels,
but if you talk about thigh or hip
area.  The fat layer here is
very thick due to which the antigens in the vaccine can become
your trap by going into this fat layer
and they
cannot perform their work, hence just as there
was a vaccine for Covid-19, it is your common
vaccine.  It was easy for it to enter your lymph capillaries.